Dan Mancini wrote the wrote the first
draft he wrote an original screenplay
right and he couldn't get it done in
town and I couldn't figure out how to
solve it left it came back to it when I
figured so I saw the the clown in
Poltergeist reach out from under the bed
that's right scariest thing ever and
what that is is everybody is every kid
has looked around as he was falling
asleep at his play things stacked up on
the shelves and on the windowsill and
have said to himself what if my toys
come alive
and I knew that that was a a premise
that would appeal worldwide and I came
back to Child's Play when I thought of
when I thought of the Hillside Strangler
the Brad Dourif part right and you know
before the before that it was it was
more of a it was the the the the the
little boy it was called blood buddy the
the boy made a blood buddy of the doll
and when when he fell asleep the dog got
up and killed people like his teacher at
his dentist but you felt no sympathy for
anybody there was no bad guy right and
when I put the serial murderer inside of
Chucky that's when that that's when that
damn square that was your idea oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah wow oh yeah and I I
could go on and on but so to this day
when you know they have a they have a TV
show Child's Play you don't get anything
from that no I do not nothing zero no
then you back in from the child's play
socks that you have on
the merch says no I did not have merch
my lawyer did the worst deal and and any
lawyer has ever done I will never
forgive him if it's really if I only
knew now what I knew then I never would
have made the deal George Lucas he was
smart enough or he thought ahead of time
I want Mercy like nobody buys Star
reactions they gave it to her ticket
they gave it to him because nobody
bought merch exactly exactly right and
he somehow kept the kept the rights
right see this is a long yeah of course
but it's just it's it's painful to hear
it not only obviously your pain but to
hear someone who was responsible you and
a couple people for the creation of this
this franchise and not receiving a dime
of it after is just
it's bewildering well the money was
always there in the merchandise that's
why David kirschner who was the producer
did it because he was a he was a maven
he was a merchandise Maven right and
look at look at I can't imagine how many
tens if not hundreds of millions he's
made off the merchandise right but
that's what he did it for yeah the uh
these are only that was just naive
you're probably still naive but I don't
but he did okay then you're not I think
he did pretty damn for for a guy who was
born in Vassar Hospital in Poughkeepsie
I've done incredibly well
foreign